Music
We're a collection of highly intelligent misfits who've all found our place and come together to enable the world to secure a web.
I look forward every morning to coming to work and solving really hard problems and working with some incredibly, incredibly bright people and learning things from them every day.
It's not just the traditional software development, it's really different complex problems that you wouldn't get anywhere else.
I look forward to coming and working with my team. I know it sounds super cheesy, but I genuinely love the weird, funny city guys that we all are.
Music
It's really good to work in a place where everyone's kind of invested in each other's success, always keen to help each other out. It's a real breath of fresh air.
Working here has absolutely changed my life, just in terms of the way that I look at my job, my career and in terms of how I enjoy things. It's just great to learn about such cool things.
Best working environment I've worked so far.
It doesn't feel like work. It's a lot of fun.
!
Best working environment I've worked so far.